slip-on those gauntlets of submission
and get ready to tussle the Wonder Woman
1984 trailer is here and boy oh boy it's
bursting at the seams with action and a
whole lot of heart let's take a look at
what this feast of a trailer gave us
after so many months of buildup
Wonder Woman 1984 is set at an
interesting time in Diana Prince's
on-screen history 33 years before
justice league which was set in the then
present day of 2017 and 66 years after
the original Wonder Woman which took
place across various European countries
in the year 1918 as the title tells us
the sequel takes day in a story to 1984
when she's living in America in the
Wonder Woman 1984 trailer framed
pictures on Diana's mantle imply that
she's moved overseas to connect with
members of Steve Trevor's family hoping
to in what small way she can remember
the man she loved who seemingly died at
the end of the first Wonder Woman film
but was Diana's presumed contact with
Steve's family overt or covert did she
keep in touch with her other friends
like Etta or Charlie or chief na P by
the 80s all these people would likely be
long dead but Steve Trevor
well he's a different story yes Chris
Pine really is back as Steve Trevor he's
not dead and to quote director patty
Jenkins he's not a gimmick the trailer
dances around exactly how Steve comes
back from the presumed dead but the
footage does give a lot of credence to
Wonder Woman 1984 rumours reported over
the last few months that there exists a
supernaturally powered artifact that
brings Steve to the current timeline
though Pine has previously admitted he
doesn't get a whole lot of action
sequences in Wonder Woman 1984 he seems
to be a huge part of the narrative
overall considering he spends a ton of
time with Diana in the trailer it's
sweet and fulfilling to see Diana and
Steve realized the romance they didn't
quite get to in Wonder Woman but all of
it is inherently tinged with a sense of
doom because we know Steve didn't appear
in Justice League and Diana was mocked
by the film's antagonist over his death
whatever happens
let's hope Diana gets the longer goodbye
she deserves if Steve must disappear
into the ether time once more as the
Wonder Woman 1984 trailer shows Diana
seems to still be working within the
world
art and antiquities and she becomes
acquainted with an archaeologist named
Barbara and Minerva kristen wiig
portrays Barbara who over the course of
the film will take on the super-powered
mantle of cheetah the Wonder Woman 1984
trailer didn't provide any shots of
Barbara post cheetah transformation and
instead focused on presenting her as a
new friend to Diana at the start of the
footage the two women are seen chatting
at a table talking about whether they've
been in love Barbara has a magnificent
punkish 80s energy to her and she wears
studded animal print leather jackets as
big frizzy hair and rocks around nerdy
glasses as an archaeologist she and
Diana have a very natural path to
meeting through a shared industry and
are seen attending what appears to be
the same slick parties with dignitaries
in what we assume to be Washington DC
where most major antiquities for the
United States are kept in the
Smithsonian in the DC Comics cheetah is
a major antagonist against Diana
so the Wonder Woman 1984 trailer
presenting them as new friends sets the
stage for a tragedy gal gadot also might
have let something slip at Cece XP when
she mentioned in passing that Diana
wants to save some of the antagonists
she confronts in the film rumors have
been floating around for a while that
Barbara will become cheetah as a result
of slick businessman Maxwell Lord more
on him in a bit granting her wish to be
like Wonder Woman
know she admires more than anyone else
according to the rumors Barbara's new
powers will frighten Maxwell who reaches
out to Diana for protection from cheetah
speculation also has it that Maxwell's
bargain for these services is using a
mystical artifact in his possession to
bring Steve Trevor back to Diana the
greatest wish to grant of all if this is
true cheetah and Wonder Woman are headed
for a collision of circumstance and it
would indeed be in Diana's nature to
pity the afflicted and want to help her
circling back to Maxwell Lord he's the
central villain of Wonder Woman 1984 and
the Mandalorian actor Pedro Pascal
portrays him Maxwell Lord in the DC
Comics Canon is CEO of some scientific
mega corporation ala Lex Luthor but
Maxwell Lord and Wonder Woman 1984 is
the king of infomercials presented as a
continued nod to the particular gods we
served during that decade his ultimate
desire and the plan to achieve it isn't
explicitly stated in the trailer like
every evil salesman maxwell is a master
manipulator and will utilize his skill
to get exactly what he wants at any cost
one of the best treats in the
Wonderwoman 1984 trailer was saved for
last a brand new flashy suit of golden
armor with wings
after watching Diana go toe-to-toe with
an actual capital G God in 2017 s Wonder
Woman without needing heavy armor we can
only wonder just what she's getting up
to in Wonder Woman 1984 to need
something so resplendent comics refer to
the shiny get up as her golden eagle
armor but they don't provide a whole lot
of clues or a special enemy it was used
for historically speaking Diana simply
needs it for conflicts in which she
needs to be a soldier as opposed to the
champion of love she prefers to be that
considered there's a possibility that
the armor could be used as a remix of a
comic plot from 2016 in it Wonder Woman
has a final confrontation with cheetah
but rather than showing up to kill her
Wonder Woman takes a brutal onslaught
from her former friend ultimately she
embraces cheetah with love and peace for
two reasons cheetah is a villain created
by the abuses of others and isn't
inherently evil and Diana always wants
to rehabilitate rather than kill a suit
of armor would fit the bill for that
excellently and make for a nice reversal
of the trope that heroes only need armor
for ruthless fights to the death check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more lube reviews about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the belt
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]